KATHERINE KUAN: Hi, my
name is Katherine Kuan,
and I'm a developer
advocate at Google.
Today is Take Your
Parents to Work Day.
Parents are going to
come in for a session,
and we're going to teach them
the first steps in building
an Android app.
We're going to be using a
simple tool called the Android
Visualizer, and we're
going to show them
how they can write XML and
have it appear on a phone.
We hope that they can
continue by taking
our course on Udacity, which is
called Android for Beginners,
and it's aimed at people with
no programming experience.
TOM: My name's Tom, and I am
a civil engineer and a dad.
ANTONIETTA MATTHEWS: My
name is Antonietta Matthews,
and I'm an IT teacher.
MARILYN WALTER:
I'm Marilyn Walter,
and I'm a registered
nurse by profession.
BRENT WALTER: I'm Brent Walter.
I'm a mortgage banker.
MALE SPEAKER: I am [? Sastry ?]
[? Nori. ?] I am a retired bank
manager.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
I am [INAUDIBLE].
I am a housewife.
MALE SPEAKER: I have
been using mobile
as well as tablet for
the last five, six years.
I do not how to
build an app, but I'm
having curiosity to learn.
That's why how come we're here.
TOM: As the older
generation, who
hasn't grown up with apps, the
jargon and the lingo you hear
is very intimidating.
But when you actually start to
get into it, it's very simple.
It's very logical.
And once you learn
the steps, they
follow one after the other.
And so it's almost
like a cookbook recipe.
If you can cook something
out of a cookbook,
you could write an app.
MALE SPEAKER: Today we wanted
to build the app of some recipe,
that is, snacks.
ANTONIETTA MATTHEWS: I
decided to do something
to do with Italian cookery
and introduce three tips.
TOM: I have a real world problem
in trying to get my daughter
to call home.
And so I would like an app that
after several days have gone by
and she has not called
me, she gets a reminder
on her phone to call Dad.
MARILYN WALTER: We have a son
who just went off to college,
and he was calling me
this week asking me
how to do laundry, which I'd
already reviewed with him,
but apparently he needed
some reinforcement.
So anyway, that was
kind of fun to put down
different reminders or things
that could be in an app.
And it really brought
it to light for me.
It was just so nice to know what
everyone's talking about when
they talk about making an app.
For someone like me, who's
pretty much a novice at it,
it was a great experience.
I really enjoyed the class.
BRENT WALTER: What
would be a good way
to get in when I recommend
coding to somebody
and the best way is
just jump in and do it.
ANTONIETTA MATTHEWS:
I am most definitely
interested in carrying on with
developing apps for an Android.
TOM: The Udacity course
looked really interesting.
I think it would
be fun to do that.
And quite honestly,
doing an app like that,
as something we could do
together, would be a blast.
I would really enjoy doing that.
FEMALE SPEAKER: As long as
my rating's 10 out of 10.
TOM: Yeah, that's right.
You would get top
rating for that.
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK.
DAN GALPIN: Hi, I'm Dan Galpin.
I'm a developer
advocate here at Google.
I help to build both Android
fundamentals and the advanced
Android class.
This was a great day.
We had an incredible
number of people,
and everyone pretty much
got through the content.
And that was the
exciting for me,
was watching people's eyes light
up, who had never programmed
before, who were now starting
to think of themselves
as being programmers
for the first time.
And everybody danced at the end.
That was really the key thing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]